♪ ♪
>> Tucker: TIME FOR AN
INTERMITTENT SEGMENT WE CALL
"THE FRIEND ZONE."
WE INVITE ONE OF OUR ACTUAL
FRIENDS FROM FOX ON THE SHOW.
WHEN HE'S NOT SERVING AS FOX'S
NATIONAL CHIEF CORRESPONDENT,
ED HENRY WRITES AND READS BOOKS.
HE'S WRITTEN ONE ABOUT JACKIE
ROBINSON ACS -- HE'S HERE
TONIGHT SUPPOSEDLY TO REVEAL THE
THEME OF HIS NEXT BOOK.
>> I'M SO EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
I'VE BEEN WAITING -- HANG ON.
OKAY.
ACTUALLY WE HAVE A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
HOLD ON.
BREAKING NEWS.
IT IS TUCKER'S BIRTHDAY, AND
THIS WAS AN ELABORATE HOAX.
I'M NOT WRITING A NEW BOOK, BUT
I AM BRINGING IN A COUPLE OF OUR
GOOD FRIENDS TO HELP CELEBRATE.
>> Tucker: I WAS NOT AWARE OF
THIS AT ALL.
[LAUGHTER]
THANK YOU.
I'M GLAD WE'RE ALIVE.
LAURA, WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
>> THEY WANTED TO TELL STORIES
ABOUT YOU.
IT'S KIND OF A ROAST.
>> YOUR CAKE IS COVERED IN WAX.
IT'S BEEN LATE.
>> Tucker: IF I'D KNOWN THIS
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
THANK YOU!
THAT'S AMAZING.
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THE RIGHT
NUMBER ON THERE.
EMILY.
>> BLOW IT OUT.
>> LOOK.
>> Tucker: I AM TRYING TO TAKE
THIS IN GOOD HUMOR.
>> 50 IS GOOD FOR A FINE
BORDEAUX.
YOU'RE JUST GETTING INTO YOUR
PRIME.
>> I CAN SAY AT THE AGE OF 50
YOU'VE GOT EVERYTHING YOU NEED
FOR YOUR CAREER GOING FORWARD
BECAUSE YOU HAVE ALL YOUR HAIR,
AND AS FAR AS I CAN TELL, MOST
OF YOUR TEETH.
>> Tucker: IT'S MOSTLY WELL.
>> HALF OF THEIR WEIGHT.
>> Tucker: MY WITS ARE IN
GREAT DECLINE.
NOT AS FAST AS I USED TO BE.
I HAVE NO IDEA THIS WAS
HAPPENING, AND I SAID TO OUR
BELOVED EMILY, WHATEVER YOU DO,
I DON'T WANT YOU TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MY BIRTHDAY IN ANY WAY.
IT'S ACTUALLY TOMORROW.
IT IS SO DEPRESSING, AND I HAVE
SPENT ALL DAY BROODING ABOUT
MORTALITY.
UNTIL I TALKED TO BRIT WHO SAID
SAFETY IS NOT AN IDEAL PAIR WAIT
TILL YOU GET TO BE 75.
ALL RIGHT, I'M WHINING.
>> CAN I TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT
YOU HAVE HAD ALL AROUND THE
WORLD?
>> I WAS IN SCOTTSDALE
YESTERDAY.
WE HAD A GREAT TIME.
OVER 1,000 OF OUR VENDORS CAME
OUT THERE WAITING I WENT OUT
THERE WITH JOHN FINLEY AND WE
WERE HANDING OUT WATER AND
TAKING PICTURES, SHAKING HANDS.
ERIK WEMPLE OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WAS THERE
AND HE WANTED TO DO A STORY AND
YOU MADE HIM FAMOUS WITH HIS
MUG.
I DON'T KNOW -- THIS IS THE BEST
PART.
PEOPLE IN THE CROWD, LET ME HOLD
IT UP.
THEY RECOGNIZED ERIK WEMPLE FROM
THE MUG.
THEY WERE LIKE YOU ARE THAT GUY
ON TUCKER'S MUG.
>> THAT'S ALL HE'S ACCOMPLISHED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HERE'S THE THING, THEY WERE
LIKE YOU LOOK BETTER IN PERSON.
HE WROTE A STORY ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: IT WAS NOT HIS BEST
MOMENT.
I'M GLAD WE COMMEMORATED IT.
MAKING ERIK WEMPLE FAMOUS, MAYBE
THAT'S NOT MUCH OF A LEGACY.
YOU MADE ME FEEL --
>> YOU STILL HAVE TIME.
>> I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR
20-SOMETHING YEARS.
DOING EVENTS WITH YOU.
TUCKER IS LITERALLY ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO NEVER AGES.
HE LOOKS THE SAME!
YOU NEVER AGE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY.
THE RED TIE, YOU'VE HAD THAT
SINCE --
>> Tucker: I USED TO HAVE
BOW TIES.
>> WE GOT YOU BIRTHDAY CAKE
FLAVORED VAPE PEN.
>> Tucker: I GOT OFF THE
NICORETTE.
>> HOW LONG AGO DID YOU DO THAT?
>> Tucker: ONE MONTH AND THREE
DAYS AGO.
>> ANY -- NOTE TOBACCO OF ANY
KIND?
HOW LONG HAS THIS BEEN GOING ON?
>> Tucker: FOR 36 YEARS.
ABSTINENCE FOR ONE MONTH AND
THREE DAYS.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> Tucker: I FEEL LIKE THE
CONTENTS OF MY HEAD HAVE BEEN
EMPTIED.
>> YOU DON'T FEEL NOTICEABLY --
>> Tucker: I FEEL LIKE AN
UNTETHERED BALLOON FLOATING
ABOVE, LOOKING DOWN.
>> YOUR MEMBER THE TIME NOT TO
MUNSON -- NOT TOO MANY MONTHS
AND YEARS AGO WHEN YOU ARE AT
CNN THEN THERE WAS THE
EMBARRASSMENT ABOUT THE PHONE
NUMBER AND YOU CAME OVER TO THE
BUREAU TO TRY TO GET --
>> Tucker: YOU ARE THE ONLY
PERSON WHO REMEMBERS THAT.
2001 OR 2002, I WAS HOSTING A
SHOW AT CNN.
AS A JOKE, I GAVE OUT THE
FOX NEWS BUREAU NUMBER ON AIR.
ON THE AIR.
FOX NEWS, WHICH ALWAYS HITS
HARDER BACK, GAVE OUT MY HOME
PHONE NUMBER ON ITS AIR.
I STORMED TO THE FOX NEWS
BUREAU.
I'VE WORKED AT FOX NEWS FOR TEN
YEARS TODAY.
IT'S AMAZING.
17 YEARS AGO.
I STORMED OVER THERE AND I RAN
INTO JAMES ROSEN EYES THAT I
WANT TO GET IN THERE AND TELL
THEM WHAT I THINK.
I SAW BRIT WHO I LIVED ACROSS
THE STREET FROM IN GEORGETOWN AS
A KID AND REALLY RESPECTED AND
BRIT HUME SAYS TUCKER, I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN WIN THIS ONE.
GIVE IT A REST.
I WALKED BACK TO THE CNN BUREAU
WITH MY TAIL BETWEEN MY LEGS.
>> HE SAID AT THE TIME THAT YOU
WERE AFRAID OF ROGER AILES.
>> Tucker: I WAS.
>> HE ENDED UP HIRING YOU.
>> Tucker: WHO I WOUND UP
LOVING.
REALLY A GREAT AND WISE MAN.
>> TUCKER IS ONE OF THE -- WE
HAVE A LOT OF GREAT PEOPLE AT
FOX NEWS SUPPORT WHAT WOMEN ARE
TRYING TO DO IN THE ADVANCEMENT
OF YOUNG CAREERS.
TUCKER'S ACTION WHEN THE PEOPLE,
BRIT YOU ARE ANOTHER.
ED, YOU ARE FINE.
TUCKER AND I DO THE PRIME TIME
THING AND WE HIT HARD AND WE
ALSO TARGETS.
THERE ARE FEW PEOPLE I'D RATHER
BE IN A FOXHOLE WITH TAKING THE
SHOTS IN TUCKER CARLSON BECAUSE
IT'S LIKE INCOMING.
BING, BING, BING.
YOU'VE BEEN A GREAT HELP TO ME
UNDER GREAT INSPIRATION.
AND I WANT TO SAY THANKS.
WE DON'T HANG OUT.
TUCKER IN THE HALLWAY IS LIKE
"INGRAHAM!"
AND THEN HE WALKS BY.
THAT'S TUCKER.
HE JUST YELLS YOUR NAME.
>> HE ACTS LIKE HE'S DELIGHTED
THAT HE RECOGNIZED YOU.
>> RIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: I AM DEEP IN SPACE.
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME TEXTING.
>> WE DO.
WE TALK A LOT OFF-LINE.
YOU'VE BEEN A GREAT HELP AND IT
SUCH A GREAT ADDITION TO THIS
NETWORK.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
I HAVE TO ASK IN CLOSING,
BRIT HUME, WOULD YOU HAVE ANY
ADVICE FOR A MAN ENTERING THIS
STAGE OF LIFE?
I'M ASKING YOU THIS QUESTION
COLD.
IF YOU HAVE NO GOOD ADVICE,
THAT'S OKAY.
>> ALL I CAN SAY IS LONGEVITY IS
TOUGH IN THIS BUSINESS.
HAIR AND TEETH ARE IMPORTANT.
GO TO THE DENTIST.
BRUSH AND COMB.
KEEP YOUR HEALTH.
DON'T GET FAT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A TOUGH ONE.
>> IT IS.
GO TO THE GYM AND DO THOSE
THINGS.
>> Tucker: OFF NICOTINE.
>> THERE YOU GO.
KEEP ON DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
>> Tucker: CLIMBED BACK ON THE
STAIRMASTER TOMORROW.
I'M NOT GOING TO ASK YOU ANY
AGE-RELATED QUESTIONS.
HOW LONG DO YOU HAVE TO GO UNTIL
50?
>> TWO MORE AFTER THIS JULY.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU OFFER ANY
ADVICE?
A MAN ON THE LOWER END OF IT?
LOOKING UP?
>> I LIKE THE TEETH IDEA.
I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE HAIR, BUT
THE TEETH.
BRIT IS RIGHT.
DONATE THAT CAKE.
>> DON'T BECOME ONE OF THOSE OLD
PEOPLE WHO JUST TALKS ABOUT
THEIR AILMENTS BECAUSE IF YOU
SIT AROUND THE TABLE AND START
GETTING INTO THE CONVERSATION.
>> Tucker: I WOULD NEVER.
I WOULD NEVER.
>> WE DON'T NEED TO HEAR.
>> Tucker: I AM A HAPPY
PERSON.
IF I HAD A GOITER, I WOULD NEVER
MENTION IT.
I WOULD PRETEND IT WASN'T EVEN
THERE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE SMOG AND
POMPOSITY TONIGHT.
WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO PRINT
T-SHIRTS.
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.